With 80% of infectious diseases transmitted by hands, it is clear that they are washed
Important. However, when it comes to hygiene and health, no drying methods
Best? Use classic tissue paper, or electric dryer
Well, let's learn that if you wash your hands well with soap, almost
All traces of bacteria will be eliminated, regardless of how they are dried. but when
Do not wash them well, or worse, just wash them with water, then the way to dry your hands, it is possible to make a big difference
In the end, the spread of bacteria is possible to occur in
If the skin is wet, wipe your hands with your clothes or touch the bathroom door
Of their pollution
After comparing and analyzing several studies, the tissue was shown
She won. Why? This is due to the timing. The air-conditioner needs an average
45 seconds to reduce hand moisture by 97%, while paper tissues achieve the same result
In about 10 seconds. But by reviewing the behavior of people, studies showed
Most people spend only 22 seconds to use the electric air dryer, which reduces
70% drought. We find tissue paper users on the other side, achieving 85% drying
In just 5 seconds
Friction also plays a major role in the removal of bacteria, where a large group of them move
For napkins. In contrast, some studies have shown that the electric air dryer has
Contributes to the transmission of bacteria, due to contaminated air in the bathroom. And we say this
Drying the hands with the air dryer may be effective if done well, accurate,
You do not always have the option! Although some dryers are better than others, just make sure
To dry your hands fully, and promise not to face any problem.
What about the environment, you wonder? The new dryers are friendly
They use less energy
Low in carbon emission and if taken into account
That 13 billion pounds of tissue paper is used in America alone, which is considered
A big dilemma in itself.
If you want to use tissue paper, here's a quick tip for using one piece
As counsel Joe Smith suggested. After washing your hands, shake them 12 times,
Then fold the paper in half, and wipe your hands. This is the best way
To dry them with the greatest amount of napkins. Again, shake your hands 12 times ... Fold and dry
Now you have two clean, dry hands, with the least amount of waste.
Special thanks to Audibl.com for supporting this episode and giving you a free audio book
Of your choice. audible.com \ asap have more than 150,000 audio books
We recommend you download a book
Guns, Bacteria and Steel by Jared Diamond, which explains the rise of civilization
In the world, the roots of human evolution, which
It also shows how microbes played a major role in our evolution
You can download the book from the site
In addition, you will receive a free audio book per month
Participate in our channel for more scientific sections